foreign
ERS on those members of the public here
at the Lincoln and those joining our
search
active one on the agendas apologies for
absence yes chair councilor Woodhouse
councilor Watson councilor Clark kentson
Ford and thanks to my YouTube
thank you
Hicks and Benson
item two uh public contributions uh
we've got one public contribution
speaking on countries of dominance
notice in motion
um which is 10th attack on Village halls
and that semester's Penny Oldham on our
dates for Argon you'd like to come
forward so then you have
for three minutes of fame whenever
you're ready
okay
business hours
good evening chair councilors ladies and
gentlemen did you did you just pull the
one speak into the Micron otherwise the
uh speaker for YouTube
good evening chair counselors ladies and
gentlemen
closer than that yeah
yeah absolutely important
good evening chair councilors ladies and
gentlemen
I am Penny Oldham treasurer of the
parkum Alibis Hall
I'm here tonight a company by Pauline
Sergeant chair of the trustees to appeal
against your decision to remove the 20
discussion with grants from our business
rates
on the face of the removal of 20 is a
small sum approximately 600 pounds a
year but the amount of real money it
represents in our budget is if
considerable
our Hall is open seven days a week for
three sessions every day and of the 21
sessions available it is used for at
least 18.
our wonderful Park and Primary School
use the hall for teaching activities at
a gym where they store the equipment and
as a social area in inclement weather
at the present time we are able to
support the school by providing a
special rate for their usage there are
11 clubs and societies all based in
parkham all of whom use the hall for
their activities and socially we
currently support newly formed theater
groups with richness rates
the hall is used extensively for private
functions and celebrations
running a village hall requires
dedication commitment and hard work and
to that end we have 15 trustees all of
whom bring skill and different areas of
expertise and interest
every trustee gives their time without
payment the only ongoing expense is
cleaning the interior of the building
the fabric of the building must be
maintained and improvements made to
ensure the building is fit for purpose
and value for money for its users
in this last year we have installed a
hearing Loop renewed lighting stripped
and Polished floors installed first aid
clips and recycling bins painted the
entrance hall provided Community notice
boards and installed Wi-Fi for the
benefits of our users
a professional fire risk assessment was
undertaken the recommendations have been
implemented
outside of the hall there is a small
well-equipped children's play area with
a social space for adults together while
the children play
the car park is used by the post office
traveling van and the school bus
collects children in the car park thus
ensuring they do not have to walk into
or cross the road
we finish the last Financial year having
prudently managed our accounts with a
small service Surplus which this year
will be completely eroded by The
increased cost of business rates heating
oil and electricity
we receive government support for both
the electricity and oil costs
in an effort not to increase our costs
to the community we have cut our heating
temperature down by two degrees up to
our level of fundraising and look to
Savings in maintenance costs as well as
asking our users to assist us in taking
care of the home in any way they can
I hope I've Illustrated that parkam
alivice Hall is an important and
integral part of the village providing
those young and old with safe dry and
warm space for socializing and enjoyment
where everyone is welcome
thank you for your attention and I hope
you will feel able to reconsider your
decision to remove the 20 discretionary
business rate really
thank you very much
I would add at this time that we've also
received uh three statements in support
of the country of dark motion
um the first one was from Christopher
West
very much on the same theme as the
speaker the second one from Brian Butler
uh once again
very similar on the the last one Richard
Pence that was quite extensive Naturals
I don't need to read about they are
virtually on the same theme as what
you've just heard
that's the dark
chair I very much like it if you could
read them out I mean
um because I think they represent a good
snapshot of a various
um size Village well I think this is old
it's just on the root control of us
explaining exactly the situation and
that is exactly what basically is
written here so
um I'll just take them as they are
foreign
[Music]
item four agreement agenda items uh part
one and part two the final part two
items
item five to consider correspondence
through the business brought for by the
chair I've got a particular see it again
uh no chair
which is
sorry comes the dark
Ted I just I'm quite concerned that what
are we to agree
and where
to be passed in favor
um
then having not already agreed
in principle this budget where does that
leave us can you please clarify the
situations
well when your notice of motion is put
forward and it's uh if it gets seconded
and uh well development in support of
that it will happen about CNR for them
to come back to full Council that is
certainly my understanding of how the
situation works
but how did this relate in terms to US
changing the budget
um should although the motion be
um down the line where do we stand here
would have to consider that and they
would be the ones that would be that
would decide
if when the budget it's going to be
changed in any way shape or form
um and they would then make a
recommendation to full Council
yes chair
right that's how the system works
so item six budget 23 24 medium term
financial aid strategy and David Hayes
I can say I just went with the
technology it's where I I guess
okay so what will my presentation cover
I'll recap where the council was this
time last year
I'll give a very brief discretion on the
sources of the council's finances I'll
talk a little bit more about council tax
and I'll talk about something called
council tax support funding that the
government has introduced I'll talk
about the
2023-24 final settlement not the
provisional settlement
I'll go through the latest business rate
re-evaluation and the impacts on local
businesses I'll talk about Mike the key
assumptions I've done in setting the
budgets for 23 24 and for the duration
of the media term Financial strategy
I'll highlight some risk and sensitivity
analysis just showing the
how the budgets can change if certain
assumptions are incorrect
I'll summarize what all this means for
the 2023 2012 budget and what it means
for the median term Financial strategy
and I'll put some recommendations and
next steps
okay where were we this time last year
so hopefully as the graph behind the
shows we were forecasting a deficit for
The Current financial year 2022-23 of
just under 400 000 peaking at just over
600 000 and then declining over the life
of the medium-term financial strategy so
by
2026-27 we were hoping that we would be
basically in balance of as nearest down
in Balance however we were projecting to
use attributive deficits over the period
of 1.4 million pounds
and the charts on the screen shows the
use of What's called the transition and
government funding Reserve I'm pretty
sure pretty much every councilor here
knows that the transition and government
funding Reserve is the council's rainy
day fund Building Society account which
we dip into in order to bounce the
budget there's not such time as we
couldn't ongoing savings or additional
income can be found and as that slide
showed you there that's forecasting to
have 1.7 million in 2122 which would
decline to just over a quarter of a
million by 26 27 so we'd see quite a
sharp decline in the sort of family
silver so to speak
so just once said I'd recap on where the
council gets its money from so the page
Just for information the pie chart there
ignores any housing benefit payments
where we act as an agent on behalf of
the DW credit plan working benefits so
as you can see by far the lot okay
I can see a wooded-based time yeah
okay I think so check
um as you can see I hope we're going to
slide behind me the biggest source of
income the council has nearly 40 of our
incomes from our fees and charges and
some of those fees and charges are
discretion in nature such as say car
parking
it's going off on it some of them are
statutory such as planning income where
with the fees that are set are
determined by government
um
and it just showed only seven percent of
our income actually comes directly from
central government funding
but a unitary Authority like um Devon
County Council or turkey or Plymouth
that'd be a far higher proportion today
for adult social care and Children
Services and council tax accounts of
about 25 of our funding
I don't think everyone's gonna have to
look over there so I turned this one
just a little bit that way and then we
mentioned on too far
everyone see it there
once I've heard
it came to set it up
okay okay so the pie chart that you can
see on the far side
goes up whilst worth of billing the
Forex up turrets we only collected and
retain a quite a small a very small
proportion of the actual council tax so
the chart that you can see in red is the
total charge for say a Band-Aid the next
column along is Devon County Council
shares you can see they're about 70
percent to double Center at the total
then our colleagues at Devon and
Cornwall police and then ourselves in
this dark blue turretch Council Somerset
Devon and Somerset um I should say five
bedrooms Somerset police and the parish
in Town Council in the bar right hand
side
so the council's share of the council
tax collected and levied within tourism
in long-term decline back in 2016 17 we
collected nearly nine percent of the
council tax we retained and that's going
to drop this year to 8.18 which I've
dropped with nine percent if I was here
okay
so the table below shows the impact of a
2.9 increase in council tax
um as you see it's broken down by the
various bands
um this rebounds Vans a B and C are
shaded in green
and the reason I shading them is that
actually 68 of all the residents within
Towers live in bands a to c so it's
council tax increase of 2.9 would be
three pound fifty six for a Band-Aid or
seven Pence a week four pound fifteen
per week for a band B 44 pound fifteen a
per year for a bun B eight Pence a week
and for about 64 pounds 75 for the year
or nine pounds per week
okay in recognition of the cost of
living Christ the central government has
provided funding to councils to mitigate
the impact of rising in council tax for
those in receipt of local council tax
support and the support to be kept at 25
pound per household
storage has been provided 103 000 pounds
in funding and any funding left over
after providing this cap support can be
used to support economically vulnerable
households basically for most recipients
of local council tax support this means
that effectively they're no increase in
their council tax liability for 23-24
and for information there's about 4 000
recipients of local hotels that support
about two and a half thousand of
pensioners who can get up to 100 support
and the remaining 1 500 are working age
who can get up to 75 support for their
council tax
um so we've got a little table there so
there's a column which shows what the
current band C charges
so Devon County Council
1383 pounds and Tyrese Council 158
pounds 81 given a total charge of 1906
558 Pence
uh if somebody's on full council tax
support of work in AIDS they will get 75
support towards their cost so their cost
will be
476.65 that's what they would pay this
year they were in a ban C property
receiving the full level of local
Council passport
the next column shows that percentage
increases by the various different
preceptors our colleagues at Devon
County Council are increasing the
council up by 4.99 but please buy 6.08
Devon and Somerset police by 5.45 our
referendum limit is 2.99 and on average
the parish and town councils have
increased their council tax reset by
10.32 percent
so the next column is 2023 what the
council tax will be for a van C taking
an average Parish Precinct and that
would be two thousand and four pounds 69
Pence
an increase of 98 pounds but for
somebody on full council tax support
that'll be if the council tax will go up
to 501 pounds 17 Pence before the
application of council tax support
funded through the government so
essentially that's a counter tax would
normally go up by 24 pounds 53 but
because the government provided this
support mechanism they will be capped
they won't have any increase because we
can give them 24 pounds 53 support
towards their council tax bill and just
for information eighty percent of the
recipients of local Council support of
working AIDS received the full value of
the support of 75 percent
foreign
settlement well first off the settlement
was only for one year so central
government hasn't sold me what the um
Grant will be the year after next or the
year after that reportable Services
delivery done this technically what I've
just read on that slide isn't true for
what it is true for and I shall explain
there are all the services at the ground
of the personal settlement that didn't
get uplifted by inflation for the third
consecutive year which essentially is a
10 because of inflation so that's
essentially cost us 50 000 pounds
however on the file settlement the
government did increase the rural
Services delivery Grant however they
then reduced our funding guaranteed by
corresponding amount so I'll stand by
the validity the validity of that
statement for now
the government introduced what's called
a funding guarantee Grant which to
ensure that all councils have at least a
three percent increase in their core
spending power I'll explain that on the
next slide what that means our new home
phone bonus funding was confirmed for
2023 24 only 140 what 41 000 pounds and
just for information back in 1617 with
you to get in excess of two million
pounds per legal bonus
Revenue support Grant was uplifted by
inflation and now incorporates two
previously separate grants to council
tax Annex Grant and the local Council to
support admin ground
so now I just want to show a visual of
the settlement so if you look at the
slides come back
so what you've got there is the
increases in comprehensive spending
power comprehensive spending Powers the
income the council gets from council tax
retained business rates from central
government grant so it ignores what we
get from and fees and charges so our
increase in our comprehensive spending
power is on the left hand side that's
4.5 percent
the increase for similar councils such
as ourselves like Shire districts so you
like the north Devon Etc the average
across that sector is five percent all
the gray boxes to the right hand side
are the different entities in the family
of local authorities so Metropolitan
districts have had the biggest increase
of just under 10 the orange line that
you see going across is inflation
so as you can see we've had a
significantly below inflation settlement
will not even reached half of what
inflation is
right so 2023 24th was also a year when
we had retained business rates there was
a business rate re-evaluation so that
came into effect from the 1st of April
2023 and the gross rateable value of
businesses within service has written to
45.4 million from 40.8 million which is
increase of 11 there's about 4 000
properties within Towers which are
eligible for business rates
the business rate income from Renewables
which is 100 retained by storage
increased to 711 000 from 605 000. that
was a good news for the council
recognizing that the business rate
revaluation uh can lead to increased
charges and recognizing the cost of
living in a difficulty of business
there's a package of support measures
introduced by the government there's
been no increase in the multiply of the
rate in the pound chart for the fourth
year storage because we'd lose money
because of that we're compensated by
section 31 Grand
but any business in the Leisure retail
and Hospitality sector they get 75
business rate relief it was 50 relief in
2022-23 is capped at 107 000 per
business so wetherspoons and the lab
will only get 110 000 in total
there is Transitional relief for
businesses capping their increases at 5
10 or 30 these are where businesses have
gone up because of the revaluation but
the the amount of transitional really is
dependent on their rateable value
for any business no longer is receiving
small business rate release as a result
of the revaluation their business rate
is increases capped at 600 pounds
okay so that's a long Prelude to where
you actually want to know where we are
so the chart behind me and across shows
the projected budget position for the
council for 23 24 going through to 27.28
so the blue line is our expenditure the
red line is our income so as you can see
as near this damn it we're balanced for
23 24. however then a gap develops for
24 25 and over the duration of the
medium term Financial strategy would
never return back to balance
and the Chapman Army shows what the
impact is on the transition in
Government funding research so I'm
broadcasting to start off with about 1.4
million
and by the end of the median term
Financial strategy occurred in 27-28 I'm
expecting to have a balance on the
transition Government funding result of
half a million pounds so again very much
like we were this time last year and
protecting to be eaten into the family
silver to balance the budgets
so that's all the good me saying what
the budgets are but what assumptions
have I made in arriving at the budgets
I've assumed that the council will
increase the council tax by the current
referendum limit 2.99 for each year of
the medium-term financial strategy
um as I discussed earlier the central
government's funding settlement was only
for one year
um I've largely assumed the values of 23
24 because this ground settlement over
the medium-centered financial strategy
have allowed for the increase in
inflation on the revenue support Grant
I've assumed an underlying growth in the
business rate income of 1.5
and we're planning applications have
been received for renewable energy
schemes I've made an estimate the
business rate income that would accrue
to the council
I've made an estimate that our income
from our shops Under Pressure deposits
will be three percent over the life of
the median term Financial strategy that
currently interest rates are four
percent
uh made some assumptions about reducing
our balances held on shocks and treasury
deposits reflects and anticipated
expenditure on Capital items such as the
environment Center
income and fees and charges there's some
peer assumptions made regarding planning
income I've assumed it's going to be 790
000 per annum over the life of the
median term Financial strategy and in
the report that was previously
circulated you can see the variability
we've experienced in the last few years
with regards to planning income I've
assumed that the employer's pension
contribution will be 19.5 over the life
of the median term Financial strategy
with underlying increases in the
contribution the underlying pension
deficit at 20 000 per annum
probably the biggest one I've made an
assumption about the pay award local
government at five percent for 23.24
with payables are two percent for the
remainder of the medium term Financial
strategy
and I've assumed that the current high
levels of expenditure the council has
including a temporary accommodation of
1.3 million pounds will be incurred over
each year of the medium-term financial
strategy
okay
unless I want to go to tell you the
assumptions and he said there's one
guarantee some some of those assumptions
will not prove to be the case
so the next few slides are really
discussing the sensitivity of some of
the assumptions and how they can impact
so
I'm just working through here what if we
didn't increase tonight the council tax
by the 2.99 referendum limit
well there'll be an additional cost to
the council but actually of 132 000
pounds rising to 156 000 by 2728 and the
slide behind it shows the deficit I've
currently shared with you in blue and
then in Orange Oil red the new deficit
if we don't increase the council tax
it's probably a little bit more Stark on
this slide which is showing what happens
to the balance in the transition
Government funding Reserve if we don't
increase the council tax and we show
there that we go from position where I'm
predicting a balance just under half a
million pounds which is the blue line
to a position where I'm in deficit by
nearly a quarter of a million by 2728
and getting support I've not been able
to set a balanced budget by 26 27. so
and that actually is actually a
cumulative cost to the Council of about
750 000 pounds
so what happens if I just get the pale
World wrong then it's one percent extra
in 23 24 and 24.25 the line below the
chat will obviously shows the impact on
the transition government funding
reserve the Blue Line the one that's
already been shared and then you see the
line below we're going to uh we go
overdrawn by half a million pounds so
this gap of over a million pounds I'm
just getting the payroll World wrong in
two years by one percent that'll impact
cumulatively over the life of the media
term Financial at just about a million
pounds
okay I've assumed interest rates will be
three percent
our photo update this slide so the next
line says for information interest rates
are currently 3.5 actually interest
rates are currently four percent and
they were 9.5 back in February 2022 so
that's the interest rates in one year
increased by eight fold
So based on our current projected cash
balances a one percent movement up or
down impacts on the council's finance is
positive or negatively by 125 000 pounds
per annum
um central government funding as
detailed in the report I've largely
assumed next year's funding over the
life of the medium term Financial
strategy however the government has
announced there will be a fair funding
review at the start of the next
Parliament and given that shy districts
like Torrid of
benefited most from retained business
rate some redispution of funding across
local vocals to be expected
I confidently expect that money will
move to councils with social care
responsibility recognizing the pressure
of that there under there will be some
transitional Arrangements I would hope
to
negate our loss of relative funding none
of this has been announced
so looking forward
as I told you earlier on we're
projecting a deficit in each year of the
medium-term financial strategy and uh
um transition Government funding Reserve
will be well not allowed to disaster but
certainly will be replenished by
2027-28 if you'd any of the significant
assumptions be erroneous such as
interest rate pay award and the
transition of government funding Reserve
can easily tip into an overdrawn
position but in Financial Health of the
council address
clearly further remedial action is
required in addition to that Orion taken
by the member budget working group to
bring the council's finances back into
balance
so looking forward
Council Pledge Your provider active
Target actively looking to explore an
external Grant option options to
increase energy efficiencies across the
camp Ledger facility and thus reduce
cost Gaza after staff the biggest costs
our Leisure facilities have is the
utility and they are the biggest
consumers of Utilities in the council's
portfolio of property
and we continue to explore opportunities
to secure additional hostile
accommodation in order to meet
challenges faced by the current housing
crisis
so don't worry we're we're really close
to the end people
[Music]
um
so looking forward so there's a table
there which shows the original forecast
that I gave you so they showed a
cumulative deficit of 860 000 over the
life of the medium Center financial and
a balance on the transition in
Government Federal Reserve highlighted
in blue for 494 000. if we can get some
Energy Efficiency in our Leisure sensors
of 70 000 on a recurrent basis and if we
can provide further hostile
accommodation similar to what we're
trying to do at Scully house in
bubbleston we can bring down
um the cumulative deficit to 255 000. if
you notice on 2020 728 at the right hand
side you see a figure of minus 30. if we
can get
some Energy Efficiency in our Leisure
centers and provide a further Hospital
accommodation we could actually in
theory be balanced by 20 27 28 and still
have a balance on our transition
government funded of 1.1 million pounds
yeah so it's just that are the
recommendations which are included in
your report so I'm more than happy to
take any questions
[Music]
thank you
um yeah
password
um and I
did appreciate it I'm clear it was but
this is something I've raised before I'm
gonna Breeze again on uh it's about the
police
um we're all aware there was a huge
reduction in police numbers due during
the austerity period uh there's been a
big disappearance of pcsos just recently
uh I heard today on the radio police are
now saying their payers brought behind
and they're 17 percent
uh real wage reduction and only a couple
of years and yet table on page 14 shows
that the Devon Cornwall police sir
they're asking for double the increase
we're asking for they're going to six
point nor a and we're going for 2.99 and
uh I did ask David some time ago this
difference
has it increased and David sent me the
figures in 2018 the police were 15 ahead
of us they're now 30 ahead of us
um and I'm just intrigued where's all
this money going you know numbers have
gone down
disappeared we don't see police ever and
yet we're told you know they want more
and more and I did ask could we invite
the police commissioner come up and
speak to us so we can ask questions of
this because it does annoy me when I get
stopped on the street and people moan
about council tax it's no good me just
saying well you know you see how much
the police charging I'd like to just be
able to answer some of their questions
all right actually Jones first Lincoln
[Music]
question David about the payroll
assumptions and where do you get to
seeing those figures from because that
seems to be the biggest error of risk
that it's set to go one percent out so
the house is huge and the two percent in
subsequent years is because the
government has announced that's what
they're aiming to get inflation too
the pay a world for 2020 B24 if I'm
being honest it's more the soundings of
initial conversations from the
employer's side however I'm not at the
top table with the employers so the
employer's side is made up of leaders of
councils reflecting the political makeup
the councils up and down the country
with a few Chief as X and maybe head of
HR and some transport but that is based
on that but also just a hundred Watts
the maximum maybe the employers can do
without
basically Financial Armageddon because
I'm being honest but I'm not party to
anything that more meaningful than that
professionally okay
um it's in response to councilor
Christie you'll find that superintendent
Toby Davis has been in to the open
University committee
two months ago and he may have been
reported that we will be receiving an
extra six offices across Northern Devon
and they he addressed the
inadequate inadequacy so as they've been
found and where the money will be going
and I think you might find in the
minutes of the meeting
thank you chair I sit on the police and
crime panel to represent orange and yes
I'm aware of the large increase in
preseason
what I would say is that
the police and chronic commissioner is
telling us that we have more officers
available now than any time during her
tenure as a peace and crime commissioner
however there has to be an enable gazing
in the future
the chief Constable William Kerr I asked
him specifically about
our pcsos because that was something
I've been championing ever since I've
been on that panel because I've seen
them hard
and they are the most vital officers we
have
in our Wards because they are the public
face of the police
all too often we know who our pcsos are
on our patch we don't necessarily know
who the uniformed warranted officer is
by name
these pscs those are the eyes and the
ears
of the police they get the Royal Intel
and as one of them told me they are the
reason why the uniformed warranted
officers can do their job in safety
now I've had a commitment from the chief
constantly himself at the very last
meeting
that he would seek to maintain and
increase
those pcso numbers which we need
that is hope for the future but with the
increase in offices
we have an increase in pensions
and it's that over the hill over the
horizon
that their 151 officer cannot adequately
see with the degree of certainty
added to that the police and crime
commissioner hopes to have more and more
police desks Frontline desks man so they
can hopefully walk into say a bit
different police station holes with the
police station wherever
she hasn't said specifically which ones
are going to be reopening do you need a
point of contact some people are able to
walk in to that police station
especially if we are in special measures
due to the inadequacies
of the concerns to the police so yes I
share with you concern with happier
Christine but we've just got to keep on
and on and on over it thank you foreign
thank you chair
but in shortly we will be voting I
presume on the recommendations of page
26. well
um
I think it's really really very heavy
heart and we will be supporting this uh
budget
um this is stealth tax again isn't it
year after year we've had this for a
senator government Cuts their funding
Global government and forces the
increases in order to maintain our
services on local authorities for us to
take the bank we can do nothing about it
please budget that's that's up to them
to set that that's not our remit but
this one is and
it is disgraceful I think that we're
having to do this
especially even after this increase that
still puts us in a deficit I would say
that the estimate for the homelessness
uh budget
I think we'll increase more than as
anticipated actually
which is uh really unfortunate but that
that will be the case
and of course we've taken over our load
of services and we must we must maintain
our uh our swimming pools our Vital as
it been pointed out in other authorities
that have tried to to cut them out you
won't have to do some services for our
local communities other than just like a
rubbish so as I say we got in favor of
it but you know we'll bring back we
think back to the page when we actually
had a labor government when local
authorities had a three-year budgets
where they didn't plan ahead and of
course uh supplementary money come
through on a regular basis
hopefully these forecasts which go on
beyond the next general election will
come to a grinding halt in a couple
years time
Mr Hudson
thank you Mr chairman uh following on
councilman who I thought was actually
going to recommend the recommendations
uh but you didn't go quite that far
it might be a step too far but I would
like to propose the two members that you
approve the following recommendations
that are listed on the screens and in
your documents thank you Mr Marley I'll
second that check okay well the uh
[Music]
very clear
record Development Center please
thank you Council about four
that's the Brenton or Bachelor bright
again
[Music]
can I just look up or cancel a Hackett
or counselor Haynes or counselor Harding
or Chancellor Hawkins or councilor
Harper or
Council of Hudson or
councilor Hurley or councilor inch
against
councilor James or cancer Gems or
counselor Langford or
councilor laws or counselor London four
councilor lock four councilor McKenzie
or councilor Manley for councilor
Pennington or cancer Wiseman
thank you that's 26 for chair and two
against
okay the next item on the agenda is
capital program for 23 24 to 27 28 Pages
18 to 262.
on your agenda uh Peter Hudson is going
to present this report
uh good evening uh moments in evening
officers
and so I'm going to present the update
to the capital program for 23.24
and so the capital program covers the
next five years
um it consists of approved projects
which we call pits stands for project
initiation documents these are each
project is funded by either reserves
contributions from revenue back to
receipts for Grants or combination of
any of the above
um the capital program brought forward
is then next you can see we had at the
start of the year we had 26 million
um with funding of 28 and a half giving
us a two and a half million pound
service
uh no Capital program is also under some
significant pressures
um so firstly we have the new homes
bonus
um 50 of this used to be allocated to
Capital
um but unfortunately the new homes bonus
as David had in his presentation is
under a sharp Decline and it's likely to
see soon in future years
we also have inflation this gives
significant pressure to the capital
program all aspects of capital projects
and a good example of this is the
environment Center which um back in
December four Council had to adjust due
to such pressures
um so this is the point we normally add
new projects to the program now due to
the funding and inflation Impressions
we've had this year
um we didn't seek any new pins for 23 24
program
um however where there are some projects
to add
um these are specific projects which
alleviate some of the wider cost
pressures
um that the council is facing
um and these These are under the
homelessness area so we have Sully house
a Sully house modular units and other
Stone conversion
[Music]
um so the next slide is where we've
updated the program for what I've just
gone through so we've got the brought
forward there of 26 million
um then the updates the environment
Center uh reduced this to 24.6 million
adding in these new homelessness
projects takes it back up to 26 million
and then also to extend it for an extra
year for the full five years takes us
actually up to basically 26.9 million
um and
the overall the Surplus
reduces to 2.3 million
now this is where 2.3 million
um sounds like a reasonable Surplus but
actually You've Got to Now speak about
the vehicle program because within that
within the capital program we have the
vehicle program and this is uh Finance
all our refuge vehicles and the larger
Fleet
um so what we've done in previous years
is we've funded the vehicle program all
the way through to 32-33 which is when
we have another major Fleet refresh and
what that means is over the five years
we're looking at we're actually saving
up money for those future future
Vehicles so the bottom part this slide
of spit out the program into the vehicle
program and the rest really and what
that shows is actually about 2.3 million
pound Surplus is actually only a uh 900
000 pound Surplus
so
we also have future pressures which are
not currently in the program
um so here we're looking at that 900
pound Surplus and just putting it in
context that
we have various pressures so we've got
the Leisure Leisure which we brought
back in within the last year and we've
got three senators and we've had some
brief estimates in the past estimating
that as much as 60 000 pounds per site
per year which over five years would add
up to sort of a 900 000 pound tax tool
requirement
um we've also got electric vehicles
um now there's an estimate of 327 that's
purely for the smaller Vans
um but also at some point in the future
probably ones that we'll be looking at
um electric or more renewable for the
larger refuse Fleet and we've also got
nothing in the program we've got new
Pence
um over the next five years
um there's also the linear defense
um project which we're in talks with the
environment agency at the moment that's
an unknown what they would expect
um orange to contribute towards that
um and in future inflation which also is
um apparently online at this point
uh now I can't do a capital program
update without mentioning the Ecuador
clean Maritime Innovation Center
um so as you will all be aware we've
been awarded a 15.6 million pound of
grant funding for this and the council
will provide the site down at middle
dock we will be borrowing
um for this project and to take a well
add up to the total costs of the project
um but the project is forecast to be
cost neutral so any additional borrowing
um is that will be designed to be funded
by additional Revenue that the site will
bring in
and it's some point in the future when
the details are sort of
finalize well a pit will be submitted to
call Council to add this to the capital
program
um that brings me to the end so now we
just have the recommendations as in the
report
um
to add the three new projects to the
program which is Sony house Sunny house
modular units and other Stone conversion
I'm happy to take any questions
um uh question marks are always
frightening and here we have a linear
defense that's what it owns
um do we not have any clue to what sort
of money using asked to contribute
because it's going to be a major in this
matter here
come on
let's take the answer to that is no we
haven't uh any idea uh he had to come to
the laws
um obviously our Coastal Engineers
working closely with the environment
agency
um an attempt to get a more detailed
project acceptable project together uh
one side of stone and we know what's
funding uh may come by the government to
the environment agency and that will
give us some indication uh but there's
nothing clear as yet thank you
thank you
um well I'll just surprise with Council
of the Lord when I saw the question mark
because we've always been quoted three
million
um that's because in every report up
until now and we were looking and they
were saying it could be half one and a
half million pounds we've got to find
and I've said before we're going to have
to look at that very very carefully
because we can't just keep piling money
in to try and keep the sea out if it
won't work but I've always seen the
figure there's three million I don't
know if anyone else remembers it but
any questions
Mr Hanks picture yeah I was just the
interesting we've added these um read
these projects onto the applicant
program having decided over in the year
what we were going to do
um is there a flexibility still we have
projects came up where it could be shown
that there was a significant impact on
the costs of this counseling curves
particularly in energy that such
projects could be looked on favorably
run
is it the case I noticed the clean
marriage representing their amount of
borrowing for some of the Finance is it
possibly the case that we could borrow
if it could be shown for example we had
a significant energy reduction on some
of our buildings
that following could be funded pretty
quickly by the returns of new production
and energy costs so have we got that
flexibility still
um ultimately yes so yeah ultimately yes
um full Council can add programs
um Capital programs during the year
um and especially in their self if
they're self-financing then
for that as it wouldn't add to the
search any deficit or anything
one thing that does possibly um slightly
is the projected potential income from
The Maritime Center down at the middle
dock I mean have we got an estimate of
what the annual income is likely to be
and where that might even come from
yeah well my my understanding is they're
in talks with
um various parties over the rental units
yes it's rental income yes I understand
about Lincoln but it's it's a firmed up
randomly rather than just figures about
better the sky doesn't it so if there's
any contracts inside at this point so
there's a
interest more than for more than firm
interest from people wanting to be part
of the development with some figures
attached that you can base your
calculations on that that's really what
I'm asking we had a business plan I
can't remember the name of the uh
Consultants
okay thank you any other questions
okay
[Music]
um and perhaps no I don't know
yes thank you
it's uh people pulled and seconded uh
all in favor Bishop
you know dance
abstentions
[Music]
27 for women yeah
okay moving on then item eight on the
agenda the treasury management report
and capital strategy pages 37 and 65 I
know Peter you're going to do this as
well yes thank you
um so there's um a detailed report on
this in the papers and quite a few
appendixes so I'm not going to go
through it in immense detail
um but basically it's a detailed
technical report
um we're required to set a or all
council is required to set a treasury
management strategy for 23 well for the
next year before the start of every year
as part of this we set counterparty
lists in the extended series
um Prudential indicators and there's
also a minimum Revenue provision policy
and a capital strategy and we also have
a review of Bank limits um which is
appendix 6.
um so I'll go through a few key
highlights of the report so key
highlights really are there's been no
new borrowing in the year
um interest rates have risen sharply in
the year and expected to remain elevated
levels over the fourth coming year
um this and it's quite a bit of extra
income to the council
there are various Prudential indicators
in the reports and these are required
required to be in the report and they
set various limits on borrowing for the
council and give our members some
various key performance indicators to
compare with other councils and also
show the financing costs as a percentage
of Revenue and what that really shows is
actually at the moment because of our
the high interest we receive or actually
it's a net income rather than that
expense for the council
um and then finally we've got a review
of Bank benefits
so
um we have an 8 million pound limit with
our Bankers Lloyds and due to inflation
and other pressures this has become
increasingly more difficult to manage
with the day-to-day cash flows that the
council
um experiencing so just for a bit of
context the council has approximately
um for this year about 92 million pounds
worth of capital go through our homepage
um so when these larger payments go
inside like the large uh preset payments
that we pay over to County and the
police Etc as well as salaries and
creditors and housing benefits so these
come together
um similar timings that actually it
makes it very difficult to have enough
money in there or to be able to manage
it within the eight million pound limit
um so
therefore what we have is the following
proposal is that at the moment we have
an eight million pound limit but we also
have a 10 million pound limit for
treasury deposits so the counterparty
limit the noise is actually the eight
plus the 10 giving us an 18 million
pound
um uh counterparty exposure so the
proposal is to keep that 80 million
pound limit the same
um but increase the limit we can have
with the bank to 13 for Lloyds while
reducing the treasury limit but the
noise down to five
and
um so then that's just moving on to the
recommendations in the report
which is to prove the coaching moment
approachment management strategy the
third party list that credential
indicators in the MRP and the capital
strategy and approve the update to the
banks
I'm happy to take any questions
I'm probably looking for you for this
okay
propose that we accept these
recommendations
okay after the second
yeah
has been seconded all the favorably
shell
um
thank you
Finance do you find the show tonight
so item nine is the potential resolution
for 23 24 pages 66 to 72
um David Hayes from the presenter report
today
[Music]
cool
okay this is a technical report
um which is falls out from the decision
you made earlier today to increase the
council class by 2.99
uh Just for information in your report
it says the biggest from Devon County
Council on Devon and Somerset fire are
provisional they are actually actual now
they were confirmed of their committees
and overall the council tax across um
Towers has increased by 5.15 it
obviously depends on what your local
town or Parish Council charges so I'm
just seeking
approvals and recommendation because it
is a technical thing that we as a
billing Authority are obliged to do
remind me
okay all your favorite please show great
recording Charles sorry
okay thanks for the better term for
Pennsylvania
[Music]
or extra Dart again
or counselor kit for Pennsylvania Haynes
oh that's the Harding poor councilor
Hawkins
or Pennsylvania
[Music]
councilor James
Council Jones or councilor Langford or
counselor laws or councilor leather or
Council a lot for councilor McKenzie or
counselor Manley or counselor Pennington
or councilor Wiseman or thank you chair
that's 20.
six four and two against
thank you Sandra
very recovery so moving the element to
item 10 revision to financial procedures
Pages 73-76 the game baby names okay a
short and quick reports and the report
before you was previous presented to
ordinance audience and governors who
recommended it to full Council
essentially the report details a few
proposed amendments to the council's
financial procedures and essentially
this support and I'll just briefly go
through them and the first one is
increase the value at which an officers
are required to obtain prequels from
seven and a half thousand to ten
thousand pounds reflecting that limits
have not been in raise for several years
during which time inflation had reduced
the real-time value of the current
pressure limit
uh one of the other adjustments is
reflecting balance recording balances on
the postal cranking machines uh this is
a recommendation reflects that this is
really obsolete because of that the
council has a year-end limits for
posting accruals and you would never
have to have a balance on a Frankie
machine that would meet the criteria
such that we need to record the balance
uh the net proposal now in the financial
procedures it says about producing
monthly budget reports in reality the
finance department undertakes full
budget monitor on a quarterly basis in
line with the requirements of our
Cooperative budget reporting which goes
to internal ons however other budget
reports and requests are from managers
accommodated upon requests which is
reflected for putting the financial
procedures a commitment to do on a
quarterly basis reflecting the current
reporting Arrangements but recognizing
that managers can ask for information on
the budgets at any time and lastly I was
to raise the thresholder which the
council has to account with the capital
from ten thousand to fifteen thousand
pounds and this is primarily to ease the
burden within the finance team
um Just for information when we account
the capital it's more complicated than
just a couple of day-to-day Revenue we
have to formally request items are added
to the capital program uh we have to do
depreciation on the assets we have to
create an asset in our asset register
and it's felt that ten thousand pounds
is a very low threshold for the council
I'm happy to take any questions before
we move to the recommendations if there
are any
as we said in that extra report
ing Governors has scrutinized the
proposals here and I'm happy to move his
recommendation
McKenzie okay
that's the house
yes well it's just wanted to raise one
issue about
yeah seeking tenders and I thought this
Council had embodied in its practices
and Constitution
Etc that we would have bear in mind the
climate's implications of all our
decisions
um
thinking about that looking at this
um here about a minimum of one rotation
of a good practice seeing those take
good practice to seek most favorable
prices and returns
um I don't know whether it's the place
now to talk about this we haven't
actually got an ethical procurement
policy that's out of this panel so it's
only in which we brace at the time and
working with but I would like to prepare
us that we have on Zumba wording here
good practice of seeing most favorable
prices and terms
but with all consideration given to the
environmental impacts involved when
deciding which rotation to accept that
would embody
um in common with other areas of our
activity environmental climate
considerations
and just throw that out as a proposal
it's so amazing
reading David no that's a question to me
well I take it it was I mean Council
yeah
it's just to take into consideration the
environmental aspects isn't it when
you're considering fulfillment so I
might be in favor yeah me on the
observation would be would this not be
better to be done when we actually adopt
an ethical procurement and done in the
round rather than
slightly add up because there's more of
that consistent um
contract procedures throughout the
document so we have a financial
procedures built up separate document
just got the contract procedure rules I
just wondered if there'd be more
behind up that it was done when they
were reviewed and we actually adopted
ethical contract procedure procurement
it sounds like it would be more sensible
what is that due for a Revere well
that's the question
I don't have a time period at the moment
um I've not heard anything from if it's
a recommendation from the climate change
group to I do I know that they've been
looking across the Devon wide
we had a conversation with David Hayes
some time ago about algorithm to be said
before he's just said now we're waiting
for a devil by consideration but that
could be in some time on thus proposing
this now I'll give them the urgency that
we've been connected to a kind of
emergency
agenda and this incorporates and red
back and in our decisions going through
yes we didn't have a time time frame I
think uh we were way too for things to
come through the Parliamentary process
on the Queue when changes
uh linked to the exit from the EU so I
know there's a number of changes linked
to that which are all kind of packaged
together to procurements and the exact
timetable
we have the best value which can
Encompass such considerations so it's
making it more expensive in a way you
know they've been clarified that and
obviously could you repeat the question
as I understand it we operate on we're
not necessarily the cheapest but best
value which could Encompass such
considerations of the environment so
that it's making a point yeah things is
a little bit of slight Clarity here yeah
when we go out to 10 and going out to
Tender is definitely going for free
quotes
so when we go to the new environment
Center you're going out to Tandem and we
have when we go out to Tender you have
scoring criteria so I remember recently
we did a well recently a few years ago
we did the insurance tender for the
council and we would have different
criteria it wasn't necessarily the
cheapest insurers is who you went with
um so the so the climate change would be
built into certain of these tenders will
be a fact to the people can choose to
score so perhaps like in the cleaning
contract you know what products do you
use when you're doing the cleaning
contract this is talking just so we're
clear this is when you ring it up for a
quote or somebody's
maybe you want to clear away some fallen
down trees say for example and we're
just increasing the Threshold at which
you have to go and get three quote
prequels is not a formal tender
where it applies no more it would apply
to both the higher levels of
Contraptions in that other way I think
well personally I I would think it'd be
better giant dot as a full revisit of
our contract procedure rules it seems to
me like it probably isn't the way to
government clearly when you're going to
competitive Environmental Center a large
contact like that a company's
environmental credentials and what the
holiday land and mitigate you know harm
to the environment would be taken into
consideration
generally yeah
foreign
[Music]
full consideration to get uh given sorry
but with full consideration given to the
environmental impact
are involved with deciding which
quotation to accept
it
foreign
[Music]
just into that sentence makes it quite
clear that we're committed so you know I
would be in favor of making that small
amendment to this entry okay it's been
proposed and it's been seconded uh all
in favor of Dr nadiman
against
abstentions
[Music]
really carried
it was 1904
um nine again thank you so I'm gonna
have to vote
yeah so thank you for that uh reporting
to David so um
we need a proposal on a second reported
report
[Music]
okay
so all in favor please
yeah that was
David Hayes before the recent uh
okay moving on in item 11 there are no
petitions so item 12 notice the motion
we have two we take them in the order
that have been received because
workspace
my next motion is as follows courage
District Council expresses its deep
concern over the loss of the right hand
from government in particular this
council is concerned over the impact
this will have on the young people of
Courage their Spirit who wish to take
part in 10 forms and chief development
training and events in future years we
recognize the life-changing importance
of these parts of expeditions in
teaching life skills to our young people
the council support Dartmoor National
Park and its rightful defense of the
right to World Camp which is based on
the principle of leave known trades if
there's an historic rights enjoyed by
generations of local people and visitors
and we recognize the mental and physical
health benefits that they bring
we are concerned for future generations
and do not believe that the current
permissive agreement is a sustainable
long-term solution
we call on the lever and chief executive
and Bridge District Council provides in
the strongest terms of our MP the
relevant secretaries of the states and
the Prime Minister
urging them to enact legislation to
reinstate while camping and protect the
rights of people's fully enjoy thought
more
as most of you are probably aware I
wrote a letter to the local papers about
the wild camping van and this received a
huge amount of support I even had a man
in his 90s telephone me telling me about
how as a child his now six-year-old
daughter used to attend Biddeford
college and even back then she trained
on Dartmoor and took part and the pen
towards expeditions I myself as a recipe
for courage attended great Torrington
school and also complete the pen towards
and chief Edinburgh Expeditions the
recent court rulings have banned the
rights of wild Camp really does affect
the people of tourage and by deeply
concerned on how this will impact upon
future Generations
I understand the permissive agreement
which has now been put in place involves
Dartmouth National Park Association
paying landowners to allow camping and I
just do not see how this can be
considered a sustainable long-term
solution the agreement is not binding it
reflects a smaller area of the more and
any Land Rover is open to change their
minds at any time
this agreement is an erosion of our
rights free campaign Still Remains
illegal on Dartmoor without permission I
believe our rights to start my National
Park need to be restored fully and
rightfully by a new unclear legislation
to reflect it and as a council we need
to be lobbying for this on behalf of the
people of tourage I am urging you to
please support this notice of motion
thank you
a second now
please second that chair and also I'd
like to propose to be suspense standing
order does this does not affect budgets
on torrents that we could debate it
wow you think there's an awful lot of
debate I think it's going to be much
descent and then we'll be able to
support it
okay
[Music]
this has been appealed
so I I don't know I have actually been
involved with this um
to the British one Society I'm very
different care of an interest but there
is a blogger called panaged man who I
would like you to
um refer to because he has something to
say on it he's a very learning Japanese
law and
he begs together with the the judges the
termination on this so that may be
eventually took me to read but certainly
it has gone to appeal
well whatever vote if we take a vote in
favor in support of Colorado so add some
weight to uh country Lord I mean
thank you chair and it was a rush to
second best I'm glad to say
[Music]
um
just feel that
what worries me is that counselor will
come and then try to put this forward at
The Last Broadcast meeting I was told
because it didn't specifically affect
the charge
I think that
things that affect our children at that
College
you can't just allow this to go forward
you've got to just put our ways behind
them is absolute essential
please anytime that people tourage are
affected
I don't think we should be going by a
rule book
and to see
rules lay down
just for the sake of it
point taken
chat by mate I just say that rmp is
engaged on this matter and has had
involvement on it so we're writing to
him but he is already aware of this is
um
[Music]
and it's up to them to decide whether
they allow someone to become big or not
you know
where does it start
s
there's a legal technicality here to do
with the consent which it is thought the
judge didn't
get correct if you like I think we can
go down here
and get ourselves involved in legal
arguments that are well beyond our pay
groups so it is being put into Appeal on
the poison of the laws and I think the
lawyers have to decide if it's not a
matter of lobbying it's on points of law
well we've probably already gone over
the five minute debate on this shot it's
been proposed and it's been seconded
they've all seconded who was the second
one
sorry yeah okay it's good propose and
seconded that
we uh we do as outlined in the uh
and another solution and write a letter
along the lines that came from yesterday
people have been second they're all in
favor of Bishop foreign
extensions
please chairman no problem not my
permission
is
um
I would like us to revisit an ultimately
revoke the decision to remove the 20
rate reading comparative form
the argument for forward at full
councilman in September was utterly
Universe the covert grounds were given
to the Halls because they had to cease
income generation go into the government
stipulations with regard to coding this
money was vital to keep these women
float
this is most certainly a decision which
adverses adversely human rights into
rural communities more than those of
higher populations supporting us around
them most of the parishes I represent
run their homes are their life-based
Finance their viability is constantly a
challenge for devoted volunteers to
overcome and yet their benefits was
rarely dispel and quite isolated
annuities is absolutely unquestionable
young and old using these walls social
integration former spaces clubs and
fundraising all take place within they
aren't just filming they are Community
clubs quite often the only space that
carriages parishes having their
community that they can all come
together in I implore you to revisit
this debate and overturn this year
unequivocity
I can write something
wrong decision the benefit to storage
finances are minimal the impact on our
communities will be severe and I implore
you to consider that
the mental impact the social implement
you know there's a whole lot more here
than just our finances at stage
um we live it in a really rural area and
I think it's easy to forget that when
we're mainly Town Center
um
ultimately this will impact no I really
really small and I'm really concerned
and so are all the volunteers that are
interested
[Music]
you don't
touch the doors
yes
when this was first proposed to
councilors there's so no reason why the
department
of wars
having been to Parish Council so I've
had a couple of people tell me they're
how difficult it will be
how difficult is now to get money to
come in and I was in this just this week
at Harvard in benefit and complete out
of the blue they said with this 20
Beyond
or if it goes they will be in severe
financial trouble and you're looking at
keep trying to keep places there in
regard for homeless and everything and
as cancer dance just said don't think it
makes up much difference in storage
finances but it makes them the last vast
difference with people out there who are
trying to keep Village Halls alive which
haven't come back to the levels of
working for the pandemic so I would
certainly support this nurse emotion
thank you
how's it going thank you Jeff so
can someone answer me this then so
they get 20 percent
support from us at present
um
and then and then there's the other 80
they don't have to pay anyway is that
right so if we take away the 20 there's
nothing to pull that short or not 20
will hold on the on them to pay okay
there we go
people
okay so all Village Halls about 80
mandatory charitable religion and we
previously topped that up by 20
discretion relief which uh costed
discount
however all Village Halls currently
qualify for leisure retail and
retail mergers anyway through the retail
Leisure sector so they get 75 relief on
the remaining 20 so they've got to pay
25 of the 20
okay I'm nice
I'm sure I'm sure we've all got a degree
of of sympathy for uh word cancer dark
is going on this but we um what's struck
me rather strange rather than the start
of the uh of the meeting was the the
lady the public speaker who's speaking
on behalf of paradise and I'm really
sure who I understand the increase that
is going to be you know the actual money
they will have to decline is minimals
not a huge sum of money at all but she
ran through a huge list of work that
they've undertaken recently at that Hall
and so much
many many many thousands of furniture of
the rooms they've done involved
presumably through their own fundraising
or whatever so
I I it just stopped me signing old that
the uh the small amount of money on the
rating at least is called technology
after I'm reading that wrong that's a
job
that no Village wouldn't spend any money
on their upkeep and consequently they
get penalized for doing their own
fundraising
foreign
[Music]
I think we need to sort of as a matter
of record but figure that uh the
treasurer involver was quoting is not
actually correct that she would be
charged but I think she might be
relieved to know
um or she would like to know that it is
143 pounds and 36 Pence a year not the
500 pounds I think she alluded to so
it's but she's probably not aware of the
75 region yeah so I think we need to be
updating
um
Hunter Jones person thank you again so I
think the point here is that there will
be fine with the sounds that it had to
pay this year which I think is is an
amount which actually could be absorbed
by the halls but that isn't to say that
if that's 75 was to Fall Away in in
subsequent years that we don't then look
at it again and see actually if it's
something they have to pay the 20 it's a
bit porous look then
I think we should stick with what we
already decided for this year and
um
all right
that's amazing
a few of her tonight and agreed that
budgets council tax increases fees and
Target increases do you seriously think
that in a new council with reasonably
new councilors they are going to be
aware
of any of this particularly and actually
be able to defend against Village Halls
should as you say cancel the domes that
75 be taken away and ultimately not and
actually these these minimal sums may
sound
very minimal to you but actually when
you're in a rural community that
supports a couple of hundred hundred
people maximum is proportionate so
actually it's not going to make a
massive difference to torrent finances
but it certainly will to the people in
the communities they're out in the
outlying areas that actually don't have
public transport on a regular basis
either in fact the only thing they get
from Storage if they're lucky is their
Council their Council uh Refuge
collection and possibly their recycling
there isn't a lot else to show for what
we do here and I think it's about time
we saw the reality and gave something
back to our rural communities we're a
rural Authority and I think it's
disgusting
um yes I just want you to sort of offer
uh some reassurance we have already
agreed that the member budget working
group would continue to function
in going forward uh and I'm quite sure
our officers will ensure that the new
Council continues to look at all the
elements uh that courage are responsible
for in the way of setting fees and
charges and what we could do going
forward when we're considering the
requirements for our balancing our
budgets so I'm quite sure that if there
were any changes
and the five percent became 20 that
budget group would look at that again
thank you chair um yeah I called the
chair perhaps you said that the virtual
seem to be spending a lot of money and
it sounds as if you said we we can ask
someone's world
but um I didn't have to say it at the
moment
um this was brought in Fairly hastily
and there were very few or no people in
the community that were aware the change
has been brought in yeah I've created a
vast amount of bad feeling in very many
Community halls and so forth this is our
opportunity to consult a little better
this time and revisit the decision that
we feel we need to that's all they're
asking thank you
[Music]
um just a reminder it's run by
volunteers and some of the Halls are
very very small and they need as much
support as they can get they're
fundraising for various different things
within the communities their churches
the different groups of things and it's
all gone without volunteers and it is
the Social Club as Council that said and
it's just asking for it to be
reconsidered and to allow people at the
chance as perhaps of Wiseman said to
come forward and put forward their
concerns with this because it won't they
should be quite quickly without people
knowing much about it so really support
the next question
but the last one that comes along with
five minutes yeah I think there's been a
lot of um correct answer that's just
pointed out that the park and increased
amount was um distaked and would it not
be a good PR exercise the rights of all
all of our parish councils and tell them
exactly what their increase has been I
know my own adulthood at all and go to
the sum of six hundred pounds and I know
that is not correct so I think if all
Village balls were written to and told
how much they would have to pay that
would be a good PF and we're literally
within two weeks of doing that anyway
sorry within two weeks the bills will be
going out
I mean they've got to that's been done
manually okay by the uh Karina using the
business rates team the system will be
generated which will generate the bills
and it has to be done by the middle of
March the very latest
I think it would look better and it went
out now rather it wipes over
that realm in advance but I mean just
yeah just to own people and make them
aware that being Breeze is not as bad as
what they thought it was going to be
yeah the increase may not be as bad as
the thing is going to be as it comes to
the last point tonight
sixteen thousand tutorials you know a
great deal but 100 150 to a village hall
can be the third instances so some it
won't matter because they're they're far
bigger than that but a lot of the small
village Halls May well suffer for such a
small amount we talk about homelessness
we talk about the cost of living crisis
the only trouble to exactly the same and
try to try to embrace that sort of money
can be very very difficult although it
may just seem a small sum to us no it's
not okay right it's been proposed I go
to the dark I've seen that my cancer
hoarding uh
uh shorthand all in support of Canada
and again
stations
that doesn't matter
all right
do it again then all in favor of
supporting cancer balance motion
against
hey guys
[Music]
eighteen four seven against the three
extensions sorry
well you're always successful
all right answer your question which is
not making a suggestion can I just uh I
sit on the member's budget working group
and it's very difficult actually coming
up with anything to save money
um up until now the only one that we
didn't count that song was uh the food
bank and I said we can't do that and
that's the only one that was included
but can I suggest that Council the dog
comes along to the member of budget
working group and suggests how we can
get that money back now
thank you